questions about the Cavanaugh hearing
dominated the news conference President
Trump held after wrapping up meetings at
the UN General Assembly the president
insisted the allegations against
Cavanaugh are political but he also said
he will be watching vazhi Ford's
testimony today I look forward to
hearing from her we could have heard
from her last week we could have heard
from her for a long time it'll be
interesting to hear what she has to say
we Jiang had a key role in yesterday's
news conference she's outside Trump
Tower in New York with more on that we
she it was quite a moment good morning
to you good morning Gail and John good
morning to everybody you know president
Trump has shifted his position on
Cavanaugh's accuser several times since
the first allegations surfaced
flip-flopping from wanting to hear their
stories to suggesting they are lying in
at this press conference he said he
wants the women to have a chance to
speak I asked President Trump about how
his personal experience being accused of
sexual misconduct by more than a dozen
women have shaped his opinions about the
claims against Cavanaugh here is what
happened after he initially dodged the
question and then spoke at length about
four of his accusers that's why people
know that a lot of the news is fake and
a lot of the people sitting here are
fake but 20% of them are wonderful okay
you've been asking a question for ten
minutes please sit down please go ahead
impact your opinions on the allegations
well it does impact my opinion you know
why because I've had a lot of false
charges made against me I'm a very
famous person
unfortunately I've been a famous person
for a long time but I've had a lot of
false charges made against me really
false charges I know friends that have
had false charges people want Fame they
want money they want whatever so when I
see it I've you it differently than
somebody sitting home watching
television where they say Oh judge
Cavanaugh or this or that it's happened
to me many times I've had many false
charges
so he said it absolutely impacts his
opinions and then he ended the event by
expressing frustration claiming that men
are often guilty until proven innocent
he said qualified men may lose out on
jobs because of allegations and he
warned young men that quote it is a very
dangerous period in our country being
perpetrated by some very evil people
John we jet thanks and thank you for
that question that gave us that insight